[Music]
I'll add the chapter in my book in which
I talk about how to build a self-control
muscle it's really important to do
because when they do again fMRI studies
of some dieters brain people who have
lost 30 pounds and managed to keep it
off for three years or more they hadn't
hold a lemon lollipop in their mouth and
the people who successfully lost weight
their reward center lights up very
brightly they're pretty excited by this
lemon lollipop more so perhaps than
people who are obese or normal weight
but haven't lost the weight haven't been
successful dieters the other part that
lights up in the brain is that rated
with restraint right filled with
self-control and that lights up very
brightly showing that they have control
over this emotional response at the same
time they're getting excited they're
also having high self control you know
activity the other people normal or
obese people are not having that
self-control light up with the lemon
lollipop so it shows that one of the
reasons they're able to stay on for
three years or more the guy is that
they've gotten this really good control
over what they eat every day and they've
managed to keep weight off for years now
any diet that you want to stay on or
that you like it really does require
willpower to stay on it I have to say
that might sound like it's something
obvious but because a diet doesn't just
last for six months it last for years
and years because the effect of our
lower metabolism lasts for years
you have to be able to stay on something
for years and one of the reason that
people come off quite a bit if they get
tired of being on a diet right no one
wants to stay on it for years you have
to kind of build these self-control
muscles these habits if you will make it
part of your lifestyle so that it's
automatic it's not a big effort for you
anymore and so in the chapter I do write
about some techniques we can use because
a diet and or like a eating regimen for
the long-haul the small things we can do
we can build it up into larger
accomplishments later some of the small
things are they there's a study that
shows that just managing your posture
keeping your back straight for two weeks
just stopping swearing for two weeks
those people are able to manage more
stressful tasks later they able to do
more tasks that involve physical
discomfort after that two-week period so
in a way they've kind of third exercise
self-control in one dimension but it's
leading into this other realm as well
and then there's there's another study
where they shook that they pay people to
usage in eight times in one month and
they pay another group to use it once a
month and then they don't pay anyone at
all the next month and the people who've
been using the Jim Frey times they were
paid to go any times they start defusing
the gym without getting paid
and so they've built up this habit and
so you can start small start with small
things make them a habit and then build
up to bigger things
there's also something called temptation
bundling and so we compare a want
activity with a should activity no one
really wants to do it should activity
all the time but in another study they
had people who listened to a really
juicy audio novel and they can all some
people can only listen at the gym while
they work out other people that they
take it you can take it home listen
whenever you want and the people where
the novel is tied to the gym they go to
the gym much more frequently than the
people who get to listen to this novel
all the time and in fact after the
experiment is over that group of people
actually wants to pay to stay on the
experiment because it's so successful
successful that it forces them to go to
the gym all the time and so we can pair
like a should activity with the want
activity to get us to do those things
and hopefully those things then become
habit over time but it is a muscle and
even willpower you have to give it a
little bit of a break and so when people
do a should activity all the time they
get fatigued and they show health care
workers they're supposed to wash their
hands all day and they start doing it
less at the end of the day and so when
they give them longer breaks in between
their shifts they find that they'll
continue to do it they'll wash their
hands too to the end of the day and so
it's important to take the breaks
engineer in a break into this long term
regimen that you have in other good
experiments that really illustrates that
is that there's one where they have
people hold hand sizes in Quitman they
have them do this a hand exercise and
after a while they separate the group
into two and let one group watch a
really happy movie and one has to watch
a sad movie and when they come back in
the room and they're supposed to
continue this exercise the group that
watched a happy movie is they're ready
to go they're at it they're able to do
it the group that watch the sad movie
they're depleted they just they don't
feel like doing this exercise anymore so
whatever it is that really motivate
whew that excites you that gives you a
little bit of a lift or relief engineer
that into your day if you can somehow
you know into your week make sure that
you're relaxing everyone while rewarding
yourself in some way that this doesn't
just become a slog and the reason I do
talk about willpower is that there's not
on the horizon right now right there are
some things you can do to manage rate we
have gastric bypass surgery you know we
have hormone replacement therapy if you
really want that there are diet pills
you can get and then there's diet and
exercise and if you really need a
medical intervention every one of them
has a risk benefit profile and you
really need to discuss that with your
doctor if you gotten to that level where
it's really you know medically necessary
for you to have when those interventions
that's a different discussion but for
the here and now it is it's diet and
exercise I'm sorry to say and there are
things from the horizon there's possibly
leptin injections for people who've lost
weight there's possibly injecting brown
fat which we can get into that too there
are things out there but for now you
know we're stuck with what we have the
technologies we have and the abilities
that we have and so diet and exercise is
still important you have to be very
smart about it you have to understand
your hormones your other things that are
making you fat and then you have to be
able to stay on whatever that regimen is
that you pick and that's why willpower
comes in but the book is full of many
more things than just willpower and diet
and exercise
[Music]